all next week to be second year in a row  as part of the New York Comedy Festival  we're taking our show on the road to New  York City that's right we'll be once  again going to be doing shows at the  historic Apollo Theater in Harlem from  November 6th through the 9th that's all  next week we have some incredible guests  lined up including Stephen Colbert gonna  be joining us she didn't yes  keegan-michael key gonna be there the  cast of daddy Holmes who Will Ferrell is  gonna be joining us John let's go now  Gibson and Plus this is exciting also  joining us next week will be former  President Bill Clinton  so he's been he's good guy so tune in  next week you do not want to miss those  shows Oh forgive me a lot of fun  [Applause]  you